[Music]
yesterday I did something that I've
never done before in over 65 years of
television
I issued includes radio I started young
yesterday I issued a challenge to our
viewers to try and find a mistake on our
show okay I just did on the spur of the
moment well I didn't have to wait long
for a response this was posted by Sean
Tierney last night on YouTube let's take
a look
you said if people see mistakes they
should send in a video pointing them out
and then like not even a minute later
you had a mistake let's see if you've
got what it takes to make chump meat out
of a master so I'm just gonna fast
forward for like not even a minute
tonight the green pigs are protecting a
boom box it's playing Kim Kardashian's
new music single and there's the mistake
as you can see it clearly says no dance
common mistake
[Applause]
I can't believe it that guy called me a
liar you said you're lying Conan I don't
like that guy yeah well guess what Sean
you're dead wrong you see if you hadn't
been so impatient if you would waited
just two more seconds
you would have seen this there I am I'm
showing the display it reads no disc
could be this bad
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]
it's a rare boom box that has taste in
music so take that Shawn the challenge
still stands if you think you've spotted
an error on our show report it at team
koco.com slash haha I found an error and
send us a link to your video explanation
let's see if you've got what it takes to
make chunk meat out of the champ very
good
[Applause]